I absolutely love a classic tortilla  Espanola cook potatoes and onion in a  lot of olive oil add some salt put them  in a pan and make sure to press down on  them as they cook for 20 minutes until  they're soft and just cooked through add  the eggs season with salt and pepper and  mix it all up now add that mixture to  the pan and cook for about three to four  minutes until the bottom is brown  carefully flip the tortilla onto a large  plate add a little bit more olive oil  onto the pan and shimmy that tortilla  back in Tuck the edges with a spatula to  round it out into that classic tortilla  Espanola shape cook until firm to the  touch transfer it to a cutting board let  it cool and cut after it's been cooling  for 10 minutes enjoy hot or cold I'm  Chef Pilar Valdez and